things happen to you like you're is it
your house in near Dover
oh yes yes I'm glad you brought that up
because I do rent my house
if you're interested two other people
and it's the nearest house to France
which is very important in this story
and it's 425 pounds a week and it sweeps
it sleeps six people about four seven
nights yes yes anyway one one day I got
a call from the police and they said
um are you the owner of the gun
emplacement and I said yes they said are
you aware that it's been used as a drop
for criminals to get rid of their drugs
or you know it's a drug drop I believe
that's the yes the phrase and um I said
well of course I didn't know what do you
mean and they said well people have
rented it they were a gang a gang from
uh Liverpool I think and
um they they took my house
and they dropped the drugs in the bay or
they and there was a helicopter that
came on the roof with some flat roof yes
and they they had cocaine they had
something like 13 million pounds worth
of what no no it wasn't like a little
thing this was a map
13 million Jesus Christ
well of course I was horrified because I
didn't know I mean I don't have anything
to do with the people that renting no
just take the money you know
well I could get more for it because
it's really lovely
was when it was reported of course in
the Daily Mail
um all the people online said oh she
must be in it you know she's part of the
game
Miriam Escobar
[Applause]
I was doing a production in the West End
uh some years ago and it was very
um unusual sort of production that the
audience it was a very different kind of
audience people would come in with take
away food and eat take away food there
uh people hen parties become a blow up
dolls buying seats for blow up dolls and
uh and also lots of people seem to be
sort of fainting and carried out on
gurneys but the most spectacular
spectacular of all of these things is
that one night
some people two people in the balcony
vomiting
onto the people in the circle
and then four to six people vomited onto
people in the schools like some sort of
horrendous
people were vomiting in the Stalls it
was an amazing night out at the theater
and get your tickets now for the bridge
theater midsummer night
are you the captain of the shell yeah
you can't Captain this ship we have we
have five captains right here but this
is a weird thing because you're all in
the film together there's there's people
who don't want the idea that you got on
they like the idea oh no we just the
other day we were all doing a junket
where you know you sit in a room someone
asks you the same question every five
minutes all of a sudden my publishes
it's okay
um and my purposes walks in she's got
this look she's she's kind of a pit bull
she comes and she goes we just got an
email from this tabloid and uh they're
saying that you were a problem and that
you have problems with everyone else on
the set and there's just a problem and
then and so then you take it very
personally you go it's just a tab like
doesn't matter but then you start to
Schmitz and you start to panic and then
next thing we know she got the same
email from the same place slightly
altered she got she she was a problem
and then she was a victim and then we
realized that everyone wants us to be
ripping each other's weaves off I mean
they just want us to be pulling hair out
and then just that's that's so weird no
but it's a cliche it's such an old
cliche that the women can't get on
collectively it's just an old myth they
tried they tried and we did not live up
didn't work but also what's interesting
is this rarely happens so like once you
know a kind of unique experience for you
all what which bit that you're in a
movie that there's women in film yeah
that is unique yes do you own sheep yes
and you commune with the Sheep
um
putting it too strongly I walked through
the sheep field you've walked amongst
the shouting at them but yeah yeah but
isn't there a thing with a stream oh
um
there usually is yeah
well okay I've never told you this but
no please some time back so we have a at
the bottom of the sheep field there's um
there's a a pond where I wash and
there's a sauna would find sauna so we
go down there and get in the sauna and
in the summer
I walk to and from with nothing on
much like the Sheep yeah they're
appalled obviously just appalled
um but um one one night
that top it was a hot summer there was a
kind of real thundering on the door of
our of our place and and it's miles away
from anywhere so I thought oh God okay
the man in The Mask has come to takes
away and I was there on my own with my
little daughter who was little then in
little nighty and we went downstairs and
opened the doors a massive and very good
looking policeman outside who said
um I'm so sorry to um to interrupt your
evening uh Mrs Thompson but Tim we've
had reports of an intruder on your land
um
and and your field and I said really oh
God when when when was it what was
sometime this afternoon
um a woman was walking her dog and she
saw a 52 year old man coming naked up
through the secret
at which point at which point I thought
okay
something has happened or my boobs have
dropped so low that from a distance they
read as testicles
I was so embarrassed with this because
this place was so lovely and so good
looking I nearly whipped up honestly
it's not that bad
[Applause]
you've got such a sweet picture this is
the moment you got announced as the
winner of record of the year
[Applause]
that's what I am right there you have to
be in red yeah
that's Harry Styles
and uh this seems like CSI Grammys but
is that a hip flask
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I had two blasts for me and one for
Adele
it was lit why do you have to bring a
hip flask because there's not like a bar
I know it's I'm like come on y'all we
need more alcohol like it's a Grammy's
like yeah we're stressed it looks so
good though it was so oh shiny bedazzled
she's she's drinking I don't feel
occasion
I have lots of flasks you just never
know
when they walked around with like some
wine but I was like and the wine was a
sip so I had to take like I was like
yeah this is for my friend
cup up
I don't think you'll have this problem
with the Brit Awards
oh yeah yeah and at the Emmys at the
Emmys it was so great to see the three
of you back together again uh
reunite it and the reaction on the night
I mean did you did you know people were
gonna go that crazy to see the three of
you back together again no I never
expected anything like that but but
Dolly did
we're going to get a standing o
oh she was right
I've heard you talking about dolly in
the nine to five and it that music it
sort of came later it came sort of
during the movie yeah well she arrived
one day and you know she has these
they're not real she'll tell you that
that long nails and she's Nails sorry I
thought you were going to say something
and you said they weren't real sorry I
do apologize I shouldn't have said
anything at all
this is real yeah yes
she likes to Moon also we went drinking
one night and we were driving yeah I'd
have my iPhone I'm not ready yes yes no
but she arrived one day is that all the
tattoos is that story I've never saw any
tattoos no no but she she pulled Lily
and I produced the movie so she pulled
us over and she said I think I found our
song and then she starts playing her
nails like a washboard and she started
singing nine to five and Lily and I
looked at each other and our hair was
standing on end oh wow it became it
became the anthem of the movement yeah
it really did Colin and I I had the most
fantastic wedding at home I was treated
as a as a son there were three tents
three I had three wedding cakes and Tony
sturdon took my
um wedding photographs and I follow all
the rudely called him Tony snapshot
which I think yeah she never forget
um and anyway there I was having had
this amazing wedding wonderful wedding
dress and everything like that and we we
were going to Paris for my honeymoon and
we arrived a very late at night at the
Lottie hotel and went up to the I
imagine there's a bridal Suite what do
you lay down I went to sleep and that
that was my honeymoon I mean well I've
been longing for a night of passion
anyways and then the next day we spent
looking we went to the Louvre or
something
said well um I've got a great treat for
you and so I was actually thrilled I
thought dinner the Ritz you know and I
put on my best dress right so I think we
got into the car and I did rather see I
saw the rich miles away but off we went
to the outskirts and we stopped at this
really seedy Hotel
my heart sang I thought oh we went to
this room and there were two seats
um they were they were winged back
um velvet seats as I sat and on the bed
were two really disgusting people making
love uh it's all squelching about and I
didn't know what to do
I sat back in my chair closed my eyes
and I simply didn't want to look at
Coley I didn't know what he was doing
and um
and then they kept on saying would you
like to join in
I said well look at this very kind of
yeah
but I really don't know thank you
track and eventually thank God they
finished
and left the room and I did say to
Connie I can't think Colin why you took
me
so I thought it might you know I I was a
virgin you see because
he never made love to a virgin because
he used to go off to um it was a brother
yeah
I don't know what I'm talking about in
theater uh Phoebe you I'd say you
learned a valuable lesson uh was it was
it hay fever no all kind of oh my God I
have had so many regrets about telling
you guys about this story okay
occasionally
behind backstage there are some Japes
with actors you know sure sure you know
you know yeah but keep the other actors
kind of uh um entertained when it's a
really long run and I'm really sorry mum
that I'm telling the story
um and there was one I was doing hay
fever and it was a three month run and
uh there was one moment there's one
moment on the stage where I was off
stage with this other actor Sam and one
of the other actors played by one of the
characters played by uh Freddie Foxx
would storm across the stage open this
door and we'd be standing behind the
door you know masked from the audience
and he had to go and then he'd slam the
door and run back onto the stage and so
we always used to do something kind of
quirky behind the door to make him laugh
and every night we started off by doing
a little like oh like we're kissing or
like oh we put a funny hat on Sam but it
was three months long this run and we
had to up the game every night
every single night and so we started
getting the stage management involved
and there were massive like hot dog
costumes and like before people from
outside to come into every time Freddie
would open the door he'd be like really
because I didn't he'd be like
changed really quickly and then run onto
stage and the other cast members could
see it and it was building a building we
were running out of ideas and it was
like a week left and we were exhausting
ourselves and then suddenly it was
getting to the last night we were like
we have to have a big finish like what
are we gonna do for Freddie and neither
of us could think of anything and
suddenly we did the math name he'd done
this kind of wild kind of like spangly
glittery thing and then on the final
performance we had nothing and we were
like we have to do something we have to
do something we could hear Freddie
coming across the stage and we were like
we haven't thought of anything
said just
I know I've got it but just show them
your
put it in the stage management around me
going perfect
[Laughter]
see that and I was like really they're
like turning me around
right
[Music]
and everyone would stage management like
and then he opened the door and then he
just went oh
my God oh God everything's gone quiet
and then I turned around I saw like the
glitterati of the London State like
Olivia Coleman Lindsey Duncan Kevin
mcgally all going
too far
bravely told it's gone now it's gone
it's gone I can really relate to bees in
the trap because last summer
long summer
I had these in my back bedroom
it was kind of a trap yeah there were
piles live
seriously I needed a bee trap
because there is a lot of discussion on
the internet about what bees in the trap
means can you be definitive Nicki Minaj
what should I say
um let me think so bees is the letter b
b for boys or is it B's as in Buzzy Bees
is it no no it just means that you know
it's saying I am always you know that's
our slang way of saying you know we'd
like I have these and when such and such
and such oh yeah
but it's really it's like I am always in
the trap now the Trap ladies and
gentlemen
relates to anywhere that you get your
money
oh so you're in a trap right now Playboy
oh yeah
[Applause]
when did you last get cool Playboy
can I just say I'm very down with this
because I've been I've been reading my
dictionary
[Music]
[Applause]
it's on here uh so it's it's all you on
here so like strawberry shortcake yeah
if I hit that word Strawberry Shortcake
noun
definition a broke
one who loses sight of her goals and her
cake by focusing on beef and negativity
yeah your story Shortcake
[Laughter]
you better Penthouse your ideas yeah
um it's like you want to test me test me
test me okay who is balloon boy
oh
balloon boy is this a sexual thing isn't
it no no
okay it's a balloon boy is a Ken with no
Stacks no balloon boy remember back in
America I don't know if you guys heard
when that little you know the boy
his parents said that he was in a
balloon and I did a rap and I said you
like balloon boy mama you were never
there
I'd love to be a rapper
[Applause]
when I see them and when I saw a balloon
boy he looked so precious I said you
know what I'm gonna make him the
honorary Oracle of Barb nation and he's
and he became like you know I don't know
some like
Godly force in the Bob Nation
[Applause]
Strawberry Shortcake's over there I'd
say
yeah they better tumble dry yeah
[Applause]
definition tumble dry word tumble dry
verb
definition used when speaking to washed
up
tumble dry
and when when you leave here tonight and
you're in the car going home uh will you
describe me as a Waffle House
because a Waffle House is word Waffle
House
adjective definition a clearly misguided
old wrinkle
we must get mentioned Viola the next
project you are playing another real
person uh slightly more famous at share
with the group who you're going to be
Michelle Obama
somebody had taken me aside when I
thought about that and said okay now
Kyle let me give you let's have a little
bit of uh
and and really think about this because
people love
Michelle Obama they feel like they know
her they own her they and
they don't want anything that's negative
to touch her now as an actor you're like
okay where's the mess
oh my god do that with Michelle Obama
but you I'm not gonna do that has she
given you her blessing oh yeah she's
listen everything you think feel see
with Michelle Obama is all that she is
okay we know that but I always say you
could talk to my husband you could talk
to my daughter you could talk to my mom
about me if someone were gonna play me
in a biopic but you would still only
know 40 or 50 percent of me you could
not gonna know some deep dark secrets
that I wouldn't even share with the
people who are closest to me and it's
all that info that you gather as an
actor to create another human being so
now I got Michelle Obama what do I do
with it I mean Meryl Streep you weren't
always Meryl Streep
oh
um no at Birth at Birth uh I had to be
named Mary because my mother's name was
Mary and her mother's name is Mary and
her mother Mary
I named my first daughter Mary oh
because I'm you know yeah
I'm that way
uh what do you call it creature of
habits no no trying to fit in all right
you know and make everybody happy in the
family basically so
um yeah but my mother's
[Applause]
I was born Mary and Louise was my
mother's best friend Louise Buckman so I
was named after her
and but I was always called Merrell my
father's made that name up and he he
liked that name and so I hated it I
wanted to be named Patty or Kathy or
that's how they said it in my town Patty
Kathy Debbie
I know oh you'd be such a different
person if you wanted to go to passy
wouldn't you I don't know yeah probably
yeah but I had glasses and my name was
Meryl
but it had a pee on the end the street
should been Street I always wish why
didn't they just put the tea on the end
instead of
key
you know what I mean yeah yeah it's all
coming out now
what is the hold that the Spice Girls
have over you is this real
yes it's real and I just feel like I've
been talking more about the Spice Girls
on this press tour than I have about the
movie
Australia I know I wept did you really
weep I really did but now which one was
talking to you Mel B and what she really
talked to you was it a message no it was
a video message on an iPad and that made
you cry yes were you jet lagged yes but
I also you don't I mean you do
understand because we're in the UK I was
I was a fiend I was obsessed with the
Spice Girls and they taught me about
girl power and I love them I think
they're fantastic and I'm what's the
song there's so many Jamie there's so
many
don't spice up your life every morning
so many and they're so fantastic and
today on the radio
um Mel C talked to me over Skype oh wow
so it's really very exciting okay who
would you say is your favorite Spice
Girl Emma Bunton Baby Spice she's your
favorite she's my favorite who's next
to that just a question all of the other
four
so Emma Bunton well Emma Bunton was the
one that I had blonde hair and bangs and
my name obviously is now Emma my name
was Emily but it was taken
when I became an actor
um and so now it's Emma and uh yeah I
just I love so give me this so you one
gave you a video message and one talked
to you on Skype yes why are you telling
me you've never met are you gonna do
something have you never said are you
gonna do something really have you never
met a spice girl I'm wait hold on I have
to mentally prepare myself
have you never met a Spice Girl not in
the flash okay now as you know as you
know as you know Emma it is very rare it
is very rare for more than one Spice
Girl
to appear together for
[Applause]
tall
[Music]
so they're not here
and James she has a reputation for being
quite naughty naughty that woman should
be locked up
I mean she is I mean she's so naughty do
you want to know what she did to me
so there's a moment in the Cherry
Orchard where I my character was on
stage on their own for a short time
Judy Dench is in the wings trying to
make me laugh trying to corpse me which
is yeah try to make me laugh
and she's how can I put this
she's pretending that she's being
pleasured by somebody
from behind
excellent I'm sorry I'm sorry Judy if
you're watching but you shouldn't be
so I'm on stage and I can see all this
and I'm desperately trying not to laugh
and the the important bit of information
here is that is that I just had a baby
so my pelvic floor wasn't quite what it
should have been
now I was wearing a long dress
but I love Judy made me laugh so much
that I wet myself
and it gets worse because the stage was
raked which means
[Laughter]
I don't think I was there that night no
well if you were in the front row you'd
have seen it go over here
oh you could you could um kind of fill
in as your host as quiz Master because
we've got some questions we've got some
questions this is a this is uh sorry
this is like a friends trivia oh
ouch oh she's gonna win oh I don't know
that yeah no well really I think you you
there's some free there's some of you
all know if they don't know that I'm
sure the audience will know okay now do
you hear the questions okay okay Judy no
cheating yes
question what is Rachel wearing in her
first ever scene
oh oh I can't answer that yes you can a
wedding dress a wedding dress is the
correct answer
[Applause]
what is the next line
after this is about you being a brat
wanting what you can't have Rhys can't
have the only thing I can't have is
dairy correct
[Applause]
[Music]
I said that line on the show yeah yeah
yeah
how did Rachel ruin the British trifle
oh
I I've the I put beef in it beef in in
at the bottom I layered beef into the
trifle but you didn't you didn't you put
shepherd's pie oh right and the separate
Spa is not made with beef it's made with
lamb sheep
he's firm but fair
you'd expect a landlord to know that yes
yes
[Music]
what song does Rachel sing to get her
daughter to stop crying
back is the correct answer yeah that's
one for the audience and for a bonus
point
Jennifer would you like to sing the
opening line of the song
uh I like big butts and I cannot lie
[Music]
[Applause]
I know yeah
I thought you meant the opening line of
the theme song oh because I could have
told you that do you understand so no
one told you that it's gonna be this way
[Music]
yes and this is for for you for me oh no
the question is when Ross stated Rachel
why did he feel it was fine to sleep
with other women
[Applause]
well done
hello hiya uh what's your name my name
is Ellen Aileen yep I'm guessing you're
from Ireland I am I'm from Jerry we're
from Derry up to the north of the
country okay and he lived there we're
here uh story here I live over there all
right what are you studying uh costume
design costume interpretation okay there
will be subtitles on Friday
so far you're not missing anything
I've never heard of costume
interpretation it's like costume design
isn't it
fancy it's fancier Frank oh yeah oh yeah
yeah all the lever
okay all right off you go right so lead
up to Christmas I was back home
um
did you get any of it Chris something
about Christmas Yeah Christmas that's
the only good detail so far just pick
out words you'll follow the story say
blah blah blah Christmas blah blah blah
I'm going into the shop and I had to get
milk and bread
[Applause]
it's really stressed so I was like
Ronald get the groceries let's go told
my boyfriend do a lap and just pick me
up no need to park the car so as planned
hi kimoy you know perfectly timing uh
silver people carrier just casually
dressed by casual speed it's without
hesitation I Sprint across when we make
groceries
jump in the back of the car screaming
and thumping the back of the chair show
them go go go go go go but taking a mind
it was Christmas and I had like a scarf
up here
what which was my boyfriend turned out
to be this middle-aged like six-year-old
woman
foreign
[Music]